hey uh so I obviously we all ended up
here in uh you on what you are were you
on down to two yeah you were on down to
two which uh by the way I had to buy
this [__] thing to listen to that was
hard I bought this [__]
this stem player damn player
I haven't used it since right two
hundred dollars
yeah
got me for sure
um and you were supposed to be on the
first donda you got to take it off right
yeah yep yep was that something you sent
into Kanye or and what was it what was
because you had like been kind of you
were kind of [__] on you a little
bit when you didn't make the album but
then you ended up making Donna too so
what was the makeup like you can see hit
you up like hey man my bad bro this is
wild enough and you know how I get I
just like to speak my mind keep it real
man like you know what I'm saying you
were wilding out on Instagram today all
the time yeah I'm saying every day but
you know it's just that's just me you
know what I'm saying you know but you
know I just I just speak my mind and I
feel like he could have just you know
left kept my verse on the album you know
I mean you had to do all that and then
the verse he actually included it
doesn't even come out on dsps it's on
this [__]
stem player that nobody [__] uses you
know what I'm saying but it was cool to
go in redo the verse get it done you
know what I'm saying and everybody was
happy everybody was happy so have you
talked to yay recently is he good I
don't know if you guys chat ever well
next time I saw yeah yeah but you know
he got he got a lot going on you know
what I'm saying so it's kind of like I'm
assuming he's not doing many bar
mitzvahs anymore I don't know what he
got going on you know what I'm saying
but like you know I just try to like
when you see stuff like that just
support you know that's right because
like when everything cool and everything
all good it's cool you know we could
play around we control but we see
somebody going through serious stuff for
sure just pause everything like you just
send them love and support you know what
I'm saying I do feel like you've done a
really good job of mastering the
internet how much of the [__] you say
online are you like very self-aware on
it's gonna go viral
this is going to be a thing I mean I
don't know I just talked some stuff I
say people don't even post it you know
what I'm saying but most of the stuff I
say they post you family so I just try
to be like just be my be yourself you
know sound like man let me be myself
keep it real and that's what's going on
what's the last thing that you were the
first rapper to do
I just did some first rapper [__] the
other day
what was that first rapper [__] I did we
were somewhere I was the first rapper to
do uh damn I just did some first rapper
[__] the other day I ain't gonna come I
forgot you should do a first rapper book
like each page is like Soulja Boy was
the first rapper too yeah do this what I
just did I was someone they said you the
first rapper dude it was real too I
forgot I'm gonna remember I forgot you
say yeah yeah it was like last week it
was last week yeah like you gotta stop
smoking so much weed if you can't
remember you feel me it's like it was
something it was yesterday I don't know
what happened [__] I prefer rapper to do
something
yeah I forgot uh so when's the tour
start August August man you know saying
yeah come on check out I think we're
gonna be La Cali we're gonna be all over
this a lot are you going over Seasons
overseas later you know what I'm saying
overseas uh this whole run is us around
August September what uh is your
favorite City to perform in that isn't
in the U.S so far because you've
obviously you've done some wild like
random places I gotta pick one I can say
something yeah do a couple sure
Dubai for show like Dubai would be lit
can't take the weed there though but you
don't need it like Dubai so lit you're
not even thinking about the weed like
they having Lamborghini you've been in
Dubai of course not they go what no I've
not been to Dubai I'd like to go you
gotta go bro you got the passport don't
it yeah of course like the next time I
do a show and see hey for a rapper to
take before I rap [__] again for a
rapper to take care of the [__]
Dubai y'all [__] ain't talking to
Dubai yet what the [__] y'all [__]
tripping okay I'm not even doing this
[__] like 20 years damn yeah almost 15
15 16. that's slow enough they got me
[__] up they got us [__] up they got
you [__] up what you mean Cam ain't
been to buy it and you got to pass
what's that I thought I say soldier I
ain't got my passport no I got my
passport I'm a girl got your past what's
that we going to Dubai y'all [__]
tripping so you love Dubai where else
okay boom Paris Paris is great I've been
there Alpha Tower [__] Brazil I'm
saying Germany have you been to
Amsterdam Amsterdam see before we was
legal in America we was at the coffee
shops no you know about the coffee shop
yeah and the coffee shop is getting hot
they having so much weed you're going to
Coffee Shop these people put weed in
your coffee right you can drink the weed
with coffee they having all type of
trays you pulling them out they having
all flavors in Amsterdam in Amsterdam
like it's the trap house but it's so
cold it's cold but I love it though did
you uh partake in the red light area of
districts I'm I may have I may have not
of sorts
we may have may have uh experienced
something of the sort I heard like if
you walk through there's like walk
through that's all you got is that's
what we call it there's like a section
the walkthrough if you need a Latin girl
this is where they are there's the and
then there's the the walkthrough yeah if
I'm not mistaken
they be in the windows
they in the Windows like a [__]
mannequin on display